this episode is brought to you by
headspace more than 80% of the people I
have interviewed world-class performers
across the military entertainment sports
and beyond all have some type of
meditative practice I tried for years
and years and failed miserably the key
is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than 4 million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder Andy Pettit combs TED talk which
has more than 5.5 million views his last
name is PUD di Co MBE
if you want to look that up but
otherwise download the free headspace
app I have it on my phone and begin
there take ten program for 10 days of
guided meditation completely free 10
minutes a day that's all it takes you
should give it a shot
headspace calm forward-slash Tim just go
to headspace calm forward-slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller and I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99designs com
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners you guys will get a free $99
upgrade on your first design that's 99
designs com a forward slash Tim check it
out hello boys and girls this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show or it is my job
to deconstruct world class performers
whether they are chess prodigies
military strategists former generals
entertainment icons athletes or
otherwise and this episode I am speaking
with a friend I hadn't caught up with in
a very very long time Joshua skeins and
that was my dog yawning in the
background otherwise known as Josh
Skeens skein depending on who you ask
ske and es instagram @j Skeens
skeins has become famous for his use of
fire as chef/owner of Cezanne in san
francisco which has three Michelin stars
one of the very first restaurants ever
in San Francisco to receive three
Michelin stars
he has classical training which of
course you would expect and loves his
high-end Japanese and then know he
knives check him out but nothing quite
captures his imagination like the open
flame the back of his business card
sports three words stark on its ivory
stock play with fire that's what the
back of his business card says and in
this episode we explore three of his
obsessions simplicity food and the
martial arts we became friends first
during collaboration for the 4-hour chef
where he taught me about all sorts of
incredible things
and this was a long overdue catch-up
over lots of different types of tea so I
hope you very much enjoy it and if you
have not yet checked out five bullet
Friday every Friday I sent out a free
short email five bullets of the coolest
things that I have found discovered
uncovered that week then you should
check it out it is free and has seventy
plus percent open rate so people aren't
loving it it is found at 4-hour workweek
comm forward slash Friday all spelled
out for our workweek dot-com forward
slash Friday and that further ado here
is Joshua's gains Joshua sir welcome to
the show thank you it has been so long
since we actually hang out yeah yeah
it's been too long and in fact it's been
probably what five years really probably
that we've actually spent any sit-down
time together because the way we
connected originally with the when I was
doing research for the 4-hour chef and
visiting the the older location of
saison brings back a lot of memories and
before I get to that though I want to
know do you still have what does the
back of your business card currently say
I picked up a business card in like four
years
so maybe I got the older version yeah I
think it used to think of one you're
talking about I used to say play with
fire play with fire
play with fire was the old one that was
some one of the guys who does his name's
Jim Ailes really really you know amazing
creative designer that's the all this
stuff for the Monterey Bay Aquarium and
he thought we should write play with
fire on the back because that's what we
do and the at the we're gonna get into
on number of different facets of our
shared interests of course we're sitting
in my house it's filled with Japanophile
paraphernalia everywhere saddles and
armor and whatnot and at the completely
different from my house completely but
at the first location that I visited of
your restaurant you had a wooden man and
right there about I would say what 15
feet from where you did probably you see
people yeah from where you see people
we used to we used to throw a like a
blanket like a little cashmere plank and
I just cover it up and guess but you
know we then we started leaving it
uncovered and in it's very interesting
if you see people's reactions that they
loved it so the the martial arts and the
cooking seemed to go back a long way
I what are your earliest memories of
either well martial arts I mean that
that I've been doing that so for as long
as I can stand so I don't I don't you
know my earliest memories are you know
like four years old in backyard you know
my friends kicking me or something the
stomach kind of got an argument but but
in cooking its kind of the same way I
don't know you know there was really no
there's no direct path to starting
cooking you know I have pictures of me
when I had was probably one of four with
a little chef's hat on floppy chef
boyardee hat and mud pies so it was
always something that was maybe of
interest to me
and and I can't you know this is this is
a super common question I'm sure you
know and I can never answer it really
popular because I just don't have no
idea it's just it was just always there
but it was it was ever-present I mean in
the sense that you grew up in Florida
correct yeah and I think is just an
interest right I just you draw were
drawn to things as humans sometimes and
that that happened to be so close
relative when were you formally
introduced to a specific martial art I
think it was six or so and that was a
Tong pseudo you know get it I was out of
Florida yeah yeah and I started with
tongues too though and you know my
parents got me into it I think I'd
always been into it at expressed some
desire and so and then from there
Taekwondo and then from there I went to
northern Chinese martial arts and and
with the chung twin and and you know the
various things from there so it was all
it just I'd done it you know off and on
and and jumped around for martial arts
and martial arts so there's so many
different ones that I had toyed with and
the
play with fire to return to that for a
second how do you use fire in your
restaurant because that was one of the
things that really drew me to engaging
with you when I was looking at sort of
cooking as a metaphor for learning but
also life in a way because you're
exploring all these different senses and
when I visited your restaurant I brought
a friend of mine Jeffery zhuravskaya
who's run many different restaurants
worked as a line cook in many very
well-known restaurants and he said it
was one of the it could have been the
intoxication of the 80s music that was
being played at the time but it could
have been the wine pairings buddies that
it was one of his top I think three
meals that he'd ever had and the fellow
doing very good then we got to get that
up to the time yeah that was a long time
ago and the fire always struck me how do
you use fire and why do you use it so
much well I mean how is every way but
but why I think is is I mean literally
everything on the menu is has been
touched by fire somehow and there are
there's so many different ways that
we've kind of explored cooking with fire
it's not it's not all barbecue it's not
all grill it it's all these kind of uh
you know just ways that we've come up to
cook with it are based on what the
product needs right I think real really
great cooking is based on what the
product needs so if you get a you know
you get a fish in one day it has a
certain taste a certain texture a
certain you know amount of moisture
inside the next day it changes so you
have to change your cooking based on
that so so you know we we approach you
know the fire the same way you know to
really base it around finding great
products amazing products kind of the
best thing in local existence and then
you know employing a technique that is
that makes those products better right
but they still wind up as what they are
so so that's just in taste in general in
this temperature texture in flavor so so
the let's talk about
state of freshness for a second because
this is also something that you maybe
made me think a lot about and for those
people who hear what sound like coffee
mugs that's exactly what you're hearing
so josh is armed with the glass or bold
glass horrible I should say a mug mug
full of green tea and black tea and I
have some as well but the the question
of freshness so I was reading about and
I've never seen you do this but EKG may
and the going through a traditional
Japanese butchering process with from
live fish to using pretty much every
component of said fish right which is an
art form in and of itself people tend to
assume fresh is always what you want how
would you how would you educate them or
what are your thoughts on the subject
because you also just I guess provide
some of the punchline I mean age a lot
of different types of food yeah how do
you think yeah I mean you know so you
have to look at it like this everything
has its moment when it tastes its best
and so it really becomes about
understanding products and then learning
you know what what period of time those
products are best in and so you know for
some fish like a big you know fatty fish
it's not right after you K it's well let
me take that back it's actually a little
complicated it's it's one of two things
generally for fish like as soon as you
pull it out of the water you kill it you
hack off a slice and eat it right then
and there within the first 30 minutes
it's kinda like hunting right like you
have a window like you can you can eat
it within the first 30 minutes or so and
it's really great and still tinder
hasn't set into rigor mortis yet or you
can really take it you know into its
sweet spot and and that can be you know
a week a day six months even for some
things just really depends on the
product what about I was gonna say
pigeons but I guess I should say squab
do you aged squab oh yeah you doing
right yeah I mean you know it depends on
the time of year it depends on the diet
and that's the whole whole understanding
of products things you have to if
they're really kind of you know get a
grip on what what they're eating you
know how much fat is in the meat
you know did you if you shot it and you
know BB went through the breast then you
probably shouldn't age it you probably
eat it the next day or something so so
there's a lot of factors that that uh
you know contribute I would say two
weeks on an on a squab yeah or a pigeon
either one and the let's talk about the
hunting for a second because we're
sitting here right you are or my left
your right on this couch as caribou
mounted on the wall which some people I
could actually see and might have seen
on a show called meat-eater actually
went with a guy named Steve Rinella
who's also it's you know I saw that
that's right and Athleta care of it
that's the caravel and avid cook I know
that you wouldn't consider himself a
chef but he's actually a really good
cook
yeah and he took me on my very first
hunt which was white-tailed deer in
South Carolina and I always grew up with
a very negative association with hunting
because on Long Island where I grew up
you would find just beer cans littered
all over the place and injured deer on
our property and across the street so
there's just a lot of negligent hunting
but Steve showed me very different size
no yeah the responsible denizens of
strong island but and I'm sure they're
great hunters on LAN also but the point
being that Steve showed me a very
different diametrically opposed
responsible approach and took me through
the entire process of field dressing and
whatnot and my experience was with the
white-tailed deer which I felt no guilt
about whatsoever and actually this right
here I mean those who don't have a
visual because you wouldn't I'm picking
up a tanned skin that's over the side of
my couch is from that first year so I
want to make these into gloves but we
used everything and I heat we also have
Chester who is uh who is Joshua's dog
here a little Frenchie with a brindle
coat I managed hunting color that's in
his hunting collar but it's my bird dog
that's pretty vicious he careful is
obsessed I
when did you did you start hunting when
you're really young or did it come in
yeah I mean III did in the woods you
know I never I never picked up a gun to
hunt until I was just a couple years ago
and and so up until then when I grew up
well let's go back to Florida growing up
in Florida you know you're just
surrounded by swamps and alligators and
wildlife in general you know there's you
spend most your time in the woods
somewhere you know whether it's a park
or are the woods or something so just
you just can't help but I mean kids are
especially being a kid they're growing
up there it's like it I think it might
be the most dangerous place on earth
besides maybe Australia and I mean there
are alligators crocodiles I think it may
have the highest variety of poisonous
snakes in America big water moccasins
huge rattlesnakes alligator gar you know
you know I'll get a fish that look like
you know alligator mouth that they grow
ten feet long snapping turtles that can
take your hand off it just all kinds to
other [ __ ] like giant spiders it's you
can't help but kind of be in the woods
and hunt and you know rummage around and
gatherer and and my dad was always big
into that so yeah that's how I grew up
and and he would take me over to this
hidden Native American friend of his
named silver fox and so there was always
this ethos so you know using using what
you kill and hunting you know ethically
and or fishing or just doing anything
ethically right being in the woods kind
of being one with nature so that's how I
grew up and you know the product side of
that has always been a part of my
cooking and part of my thought process
and and and in fact I went you know from
that to the big city to being vegetarian
to be a pescetarian - vegetarian - vegan
and then finally back to hunting again
after becoming chefs what led you from
what led you out was there any
particular moment that led you out of
veganism or realization or I taste hey
you know what you know it was actually I
just made there so there was I was
training again I I took a brief moment
off a training when I went to school and
this was FCI
Culinary Institute it used to be called
back then it's now called the ICC or
something right
and and back then it was a bunch of
crazy old French dudes some very
well-known French chefs in New York City
yeah in New York City and so I went into
school being kind of a vegetarian and
culinary school and I remember tasting
this neatness like god this is [ __ ]
disgusting
this is like you know like because it's
commodity veal right you're talking
about you know feedlot cows and stuff
and that's really nasty stuff and so the
point was is that I had a dream one
night and I was vegetarian at that point
not vegan anymore and I I was in a river
I was standing in a river and I just
reached down in and I grabbed a giant
squid out and I just bit into it and bit
a big hunk of squid and so then I woke
up and the next day I woke up and I had
this craving for salt and pepper squid
and so I wouldn't got salt and pepper
squid it was the best thing I've ever
eaten
and those that's how I got out of it and
that was it was the gateway on at the
time you were training in bagua or what
were you getting can you describe that
for people who are not familiar so so
there there the typical path to Chinese
martial arts as a kid when you start
very young you start in like long fists
right which is a normal either either
southern or Northern you know you pick
what's best for your body type so if you
have longer you know limbs then usually
long fist is the way to go so and then
you can kind of choose after you do that
for your years of basics and once you
get three years of basics which you know
take you know ten years or so then you
can kind of start to choose what you
want to really kind of specialize in or
what you have attitude towards depending
on you know not just your body type but
also your your sensibility and your
movement and and so I chose internal
martial arts which is the family of
three Tai Chi
Chingy and ba gua and so I chose all
three of those right and I started in
Taiji because my teacher in Florida was
a student of chin chuang and chuang is a
really amazing Taiji teacher from Chen
village in China and and I just traced
up the lineage from there so when I left
Florida in high school I just traced a
lineage back and and and started doing
shinny and bagua and bagua was always
very interesting to me
and then I got just and I just
specialized in bagua and then when I
moved out that was I don't know ten
years before I moved here and I moved
here about twelve years ago and and then
I moved out here and I traced my lineage
back to the last surviving member of
food style bagua and his name was Leon
Sean yeah and he just passed away a
couple years ago but I studied with him
for about ten years until his death and
I was supposed to describe bagua right
yeah yeah yeah yeah soso bagua I mean
you know it's one of those it's a it's a
kind of esoteric martial art and it's
really hard to describe I don't know
that there's a really a two-sentence
description for bagua but if if I could
if I could it would be evasion and I
think it's kind of the art of evasion
but there's all these kind of
prerequisites to to that and I think
that it's really hard even more hard to
describe because most of our
understanding in America of really high
level Chinese martial arts is total
garbage
right there's I don't know if there is
even one to be honest with you well I
mean you could probably kind of when
you're on your hands right right they
get really good Chinese martial that it
would be effective but in terms of you
know healthfulness it's a really amazing
thing so you kind of walk in circles
until you get dizzy and then you're no
longer it is anymore and then you learn
how to do these little patterns where
you go back and forth and up and down
and it teaches you basically to have a
very supple strong flexible series of
movements that can react at any time to
someone else's movements and and kind of
almost confuse them if you will or just
evade just enough to where you always
have the angular upper hand and he's
when I when I've thought of Bhagwan I
don't I know very little about it even
though I lived in in China for six
months in 92 and went to two
universities there in Beijing where I
studied something called the Chung
for a period of time you could abate
that I would you know I went to there's
one called oddly enough in English
Beijing Normal University which is
Beijing or chiffon Dasha and then
there's Beijing Capital University of
Business & Economics which is show
looting mall Dasha but they call it the
yeah gingy maharashtrian so that those
were the two and with bog why only I
remember seeing someone practicing and I
the BA I guess is eight I don't know
what it refers to but there's some
relationship to what are they the
trigrams of log waz basically like is
the eight trigrams right yeah the eight
trigrams and so somehow this relates
back to a philosophy of you know the
beginning of everything it's a binary
system essentially to where there was
there's a there's you know the void
starts with wuji right and then there's
the void and then there's one and zero
and one binaries and then it builds from
there and I don't really know yeah that
wasn't my purpose for studying things I
never really I never understood it
and I still don't today so the cosmology
aspect of it
how has if it has the martial arts
affected how you think about food
cooking or vice versa I think it affects
everything right I think it affects the
way that you really think and act and
everything you do and I mean you know
the just overall the ability to be more
peaceful with your surroundings but I
think that in cooking I think it's the
essential nature right we're a
restaurant I mean if you were to ask me
what saison is I would say it's a
restaurant and there what kind of
restaurant well it's American food
because there's no you know I think and
that's the part where martial arts kicks
in because you're not it's meant to be
the essential parts of things right in
life and where you're stripping away all
of the unofficial to get to the
essential right right and and so that
maybe you know taste maybe the the
actual dish itself
in in the restaurant where you just have
what's essential on the plate you have a
beautiful piece of wild you know deer or
elk or whatever it may be one that I
hunted in a good place at the right time
of year and you just age it just enough
to get to its sweet spot and you just
barely grill it and you just put a
beautiful sauce on the plate right and
that's the essential part of what
pleasure is right and so that's the same
with the service right I mean here is
the description it's very simple it's
very basic we want to get in give the
person their food get out let them have
a pleasurable experience right so all of
it is kind of reflected the whole
philosophy of the restaurant and
everything else is reflected through you
know those those kind of principles I
think that's very martial arts right oh
it is yeah well I mean I think that the
you know they their parallels in all
these things and the reason part of the
reason I want to have you on is because
I know you have this deep love and
obsession with the Chinese martial arts
and internal martial arts and so I've
been fantasizing in part myself of doing
so hey just keep laughing cuz dog like a
prairie dog keeps popping up because he
wants to get on the couch but I've been
fantasizing about doing a second podcast
I don't think I'm going to called side
gig because I think that what we do as
the primary activity is people view it
is so informed by what other obsessions
we might have and vice versa the so the
question of reducing and simplifying I
think transfers across all these
different areas right you look at people
who are really world-class as athletic
Coaches they're there's one track and
field coach I remember I think he was
Dutch who said you know do as little as
is necessary not as much as as possible
right you could apply that to your food
you could apply that to bagua anything
really of life yeah and starting destroy
your cats or seven Chester's having a
nervous breakdown what do you think has
made saison unique and successful as a
restaurant
well I mean I think that at the end of
the day it was about that actually that
just the philosophy the ethos of the the
restaurant and because you know it
started with just the food you know you
know asking myself you know series of
questions about what I thought about the
food and the quality and the
essentialness of everything and I think
that triggered everything else and that
was you know really starting and saying
okay yeah you know when we first before
even starts a song it's really just my
thought process about how to create good
food and and is this let's say I'm
making a dish and I eat I eat it and I
get to and I say is this really the best
version of this thing that I've ever
eaten or ever put in my mouth you know
the answer it's either yes or no and the
answer is no then I have to start over
and I have to really think through the
reality of what and just keeping
yourself grounded and thinking and what
what is the reality of if you know mr.
Joel Robuchon came in or something what
would he say or what would the best chef
in Japan say you know and so that it was
that kind of process what I think is is
certainly influenced by martial arts and
that's that's how it all started I guess
how have you responded when what is your
internal dialogue or self-talk like when
you get say a review from a critic that
you wish were better or will get those
anymore but I want you to correct my
time line if I'm wrong but so let's I'm
gonna use my flawed memory to try to
just paint a picture here so we
connected when you're at the old
location much smaller location we kept
in touch hit it off you ended up then
developing the new location which I
wanted to invest in purely and this is
the only time I don't know if I ever
told you this is the only time I've ever
done it where I made the investment
viewing it like is gonna sound silly
maybe but I ate a patron
rant in a way because I enjoyed your
work so much I just wanted to see what
you would do next and so it's like a
what it's I cared more about you being
able to continue to experiment and
refine what you were doing then I cared
about ever seeing that come back now
the restaurants done extremely well but
that was the reason for doing it and
then the I remember one point there was
it wasn't a bad review but it wasn't
like a flawless review that came out and
we had a little bit of communication and
there wasn't really say anything and you
just went heads down and then it was
like maybe a year later that you became
is it one of the one of the two
restaurants ever to receive three
Michelin stars in San Francisco yeah
instead we were the first along with one
other restaurant yeah Ben knew right
Yeah right and when when you get either
an imperfect review or a great review
what do you say to yourself well I mean
you know reviews or you know the whole
whole media it's a great validation in
some ways to hard work but at the end
the day you know if those things didn't
exist you know masses in the seats are
really what would make you enjoy your
life right and and so you know for that
reason it's just you have to just I mean
there's learning tools there you know
you get a bad review then you have to
really think about it you know is this
really true you know it's important to
you know take in what's what's real and
discard what's not right because we know
the media is it can be a little silly
sometimes
so or inaccurate let's say but but there
is also a lot of really knowledgeable
people out that have traveled the world
and and I don't know to be honest with
you I don't think about it anymore
I don't think about anymore because when
I see people come in the restaurant and
really have such an amazing time that's
what's kind of special to me that's what
that's what makes it worth it
it's very you know simple in a way and
I'm a must simple simple dude in many
ways well the I remember the first time
I did a I guess I'm not sure if I would
call a chef's table
I think it was a chef's table dinner at
saison and the lease there were a couple
of simple and I was looking for things
that I could share in the 4-hour chef
read things that people could try test
themselves and one of them was so simple
but so well done and I want you to
describe it I don't remember the name
but it was effectively a piece of cling
wrap on top of a not a martini glass but
a very nice piece of glassware oh the
magic Bowl there we get a magic Bowl the
magic and you describe this and then a
piece we would suspect
so it's just like it's it's been around
for a long time but it's basically just
you stretch a piece of saran wrap over
the top of a glass bowl or any Bowl
really for that matter where the
basically stretch it far enough around
the edges so that when you rip it off
the top seems like it's floating on air
right so you can't really tell that
there's saran wrap there and that yeah
people love that and then use it looks
like the food's floating you put a piece
of food on top of the saran wrap it
looks like the food is floating yeah
it's it's just but it's a very I'd never
seen now I think it's totally ridiculous
and I would never do it again well it
was fun at the time it was fun so what
is experimenting with these days what
are you most excited to work on or
experiment with it's its products you
know as time goes on you know just like
if you practice your you know your
martial arts over and over again
you do that one throw you know millions
of times if you can and then that's when
it really starts to get interesting it's
the same way with cooking like you do
you repeat the same process over and
over and over again
thousands of thousand times and you
start to you know get a little better
understanding of it and then another few
thousand times goodbye I start to get a
little more better understanding of it
and then you maybe start to look at your
products a little differently you start
to chase down better products you're you
know a little bit less salt more natural
flavor comes out you know there there's
it's such subtle little differences and
but that's really what makes up really
really great cooking is just all of
those little tiny things done really
well
throughout a process that you've
repeated you know thousands and
thousands of times
mm-hmm well it makes me think of Bruce
Lee right I mean and I'm gonna butcher
the quote but one lines I might I don't
fear the man who's practiced 10,000
kicks one time eh I fear the man just
practiced one kick 10,000 times right
exactly
well that's really what it's about
because in that that's from Marshall are
you know the more I talk about it the
more it comes back to really just
martial arts and practicing because we
used to you know we still when I was
young we would practice the same throw
for hours and hours and hours again I'll
just do that throat over and over and
over again that's all we didn't do until
we could just do it no matter what right
until its default until it's you know
you go through those isolation drills
where you basically isolate everything
that you do and your arsenal and then
you do it so many times that it's there
when you need it no matter what right
that's that's same with cooking right
same with anything I get mad you know on
demand repertoire yeah what's it make it
part of your on-demand repertoire yeah
you can call it when do I need it yeah I
sit of the in if you were to think of
some of the biggest influences or
mentors they don't have to be from
cooking but in your sort of development
as a chef as a cook who who are some of
the names that come to mind or people
who come to mind you know that I don't
know it's a great question is you take
influence from everywhere this is
another question that happens sometimes
that I can't ever answer I'm sure there
are a ton of them but I'm not gonna let
you go with there they're everywhere I'm
gonna I want it they they are everywhere
but I yeah just I'm looking for any any
specific lessons learned so for instance
I'll give you an example one of my
friends who used to work at one of Danny
Meyer's very first restaurants no it
wasn't a Danny well he did he did do
that but he worked with this very famous
French chef at one point and he so he
wanted to he ended up teaching this guy
Jeffrey how to move through the kitchen
without being underfoot and like getting
in the way of everyone else and he would
always say to me go Jeffrey you
like my dick always between my legs and
he would help Adam but he that is one of
the lessons that he learned was just how
to navigate moving between line cooks
and so on right so like in the school of
hard knocks I'm like running through my
head right now to try to find an example
and I and you know I think what the
problem is with me is that I don't
remember [ __ ] my memory is absolutely
terrible and in many ways because I
think that my process is feelings and
shapes and you know here's a here is an
image that triggers a memory here is a
you know a feeling that creates a
thought and I guess that's the same for
everybody I don't know but but maybe
it's just that my memory really sucks
but if I really could I mean if I could
if I could look at mentors and it would
have to be probably my one of my first
martial arts teachers in Florida Chinese
martial arts as kamle and he was just he
was this guy who was just you know his
shorter stockier dude and he would just
practice everything that he preached he
was a living example of of everything
real around him and and truthful and
kind of sincere and honest and but he
was also you know real badass on the
side like he would I mean like he could
just throw it to the ground I just that
there was just no but he wouldn't ever
unless you're training right and so he
just embodied this kind of peacefulness
and helpfulness and patience and all
these things and I don't know I lost the
patience a long time ago so I didn't
really do well with that example but but
uh but in many ways you know I still
look back to him I know all the time
just just based on those simple you know
kind of simple examples that he provided
that are you know simple to say but
really hard to do yeah you know he what
would have been some of the
fist times for you professionally or
personally opening Cezanne open is both
a great time and a really tough time in
the beginning I may work you know we
were in an alley right when we started
and it's one day a week and we started
it because I was I was unhappy and my my
you know consulting job that I was doing
I was I wound up being broke after
spending all my money in 2007 or
whatever it is I'm you know 2007 was
very kind of a prosperous year for money
for me and I made a bunch of money but
then I wound up I thought I was just
gonna keep coming and then all of sudden
everything crash was like oh she had I
screwed this one up so I said you know
if I'm gonna be broke I'd rather be
happy and broke then then you know
miserable and broke and so that's why I
started saison it gave me the the kind
of like courage to just say you know
what [ __ ] it I'm just gonna jump out on
my own here and just do what I really
want to do what I really believe in and
that started is just a simple thing one
night a week you know in a in an alley
really right now the one night a week
was that because you were renting the
space from someone else just for once a
week and that's what you could afford or
was it that that was the only way you
could really prepare well there's no
deposit so that's why we could have
worked it ya know but we we started we
started with like 10 grand right of our
own money it was just he was two
thousand dollars and I was that we we
had there was one opening in this event
space which was the old saison and we
just you know Sunday nights it's a zone
we started something nice to say zone I
just wanted to cook again and and so we
we went we bought some pots we bought
some plates and we we get we went jumps
into it yeah what were what were the
hardest experiences in those first few
months for you oh right so to get back
to the original question you know we we
started this thing inside a cafe that
I'm sure they're gonna be very angry
once I expose all this but there's
there's this cafe and they would just
had they just had really bad practices
and and we you know worked out a deal to
where we would do you know our Sunday
nights but they would always get in the
way or like some of their work
would come in and just like touch our
food and [ __ ] that we spent three months
you know trying to perfect my god or we
had you know like we would have like
these beautiful like ferments that we
made from like three years ago
what are clearance well just like oh
like ferment or something there you got
a pot of pickles in the backyard that
I've had for you know seven years that
have been aging carefully and now
they're amazing and then you know you
got this knucklehead coming in and like
spilling [ __ ] on top of God and and the
dish pit was shared so the dish where
the dishwashing happened was shared
between the old saison and the cafe and
it was just a nightmare and the place
would flood every year with sewage water
and rip everything out throw everything
away I start over I mean it was just it
was it was it was like the most volatile
place ever so it was I mean you know
what's funny about that is that the day
that we were moving out you know we got
all our investments to move to the new
location that was like four years ago
now I think in and the day that we were
moving out it was we had finished
service for the night you know great
last service we hired movers 75028 and
we fell asleep I fell asleep on the you
know on the stool outside just waiting
for the movers to show back up because
they need to go get breakfast or
something they're supposed to just take
all the [ __ ] and then all of a sudden I
woke up to somebody screaming [ __ ] it's
flooding there's [ __ ] water
everywhere and in within 15 minutes the
the get whatever the system was unfold
some Street is really the worst
infrastructure in all of San Francisco
and within 15 minutes we were under
three feet of water about here because
there is a gradient and it went down and
you know from the street level was
approximately 2 or 3 feet higher than
then the back of the restaurant and so
all of our stuff that we packed up was
completely soaked in sewage water you
have pictures of like Marc bright you
know there's so many yeah floating on a
bear on a wine barrel out in there you
know a little laugh so in his hands but
he may just is ridiculous so that was
that was how we ended
that's always ended the old space and I
was through everything else forever
okay so in a situation like that the
catastrophe strikes uh how do you
contend with that mentally it yourself I
mean is there a person you call do you
just go [ __ ] smash on the wooden man
friend at 17 hours straight what do you
do I just die I just it's all internal
it's all I just I just I was just
thinking to myself you know just kind of
exasperated and and I cuz I lost all my
old books from my culinary school and
like every note that I've ever taken for
you know ten years or so or 15 years was
in that flood like oh my worst
nightmares all the ideas of like any any
thing that was truly unique to my
thoughts you sound like me I've just got
like bookshelves of notebooks yeah so
all those just gone in sewage and all
the ink was running on them and I was
like it that that was the everything
else is replaceable but that was really
truly the thing where I looked at it and
I was like [ __ ] I just had to sit down
for a while and and but you know we're
moving into the new space so there's a
positive spin I was like you know [ __ ]
it we're just gonna start over and it's
the same thing we started with it's it's
all up there somewhere I know not those
exact things but you just got to start
over
well I've been brewing on something very
similar happened to a guy had on the
podcast recently named Cal fuss man So
Cal is one of the most masterful
interviewers I've ever met he did the
what I've learned series probably about
60% of it for Esquire magazine so he's
interviewed everybody like Gorbachev
Clooney like you name it it's everybody
and at one point he'd been working on
this piece like a year and a half and it
was in the basement of some I think
relatives house and it flooded and he
lost all of his notes for a piece he'd
been working on for a year about
becoming for a day a sommelier on top of
the World Trade Center because because
9/11 happened and like interrupted
everything of course I mean huge tragedy
he wasn't sure you should give him work
on it and the advice that he was given
by I can suppose a mentor who just said
the good [ __ ] sticks
it's like sit down and write it he's
like the good [ __ ] sticks what did you
uh what were the best decisions that you
made with the new space so in a way I
mean you get this flood notes are gone
you're starting from
I mean scratching away right if to get
it you have to buy well they was
starting over actually I think I think I
think the best decision I made was just
to say okay screw it let's let's really
start over let's there's just it's just
completely empty Eric up here and really
think about now and and what is really
valuable you know what's really valuable
to me now what what's honest
what's sincere about what we're doing
and and let's do that and and that's
really still the driver to to saison now
when you have people come in when you
hire people to cook at the restaurant
really Chester keeps a farting right and
way yeah he's he's out cold
so this looks kind of like a little pork
chop in there there's there is I went
Pig honey I go all the time but I went
in last month north and your and I like
to the west of Red Bluff near menacing a
National Forest got it and in there pig
dogs on one of the hunts and and they're
all in the truck and so we were walking
by I walked by with Chester and they
thought he's a pig I think because they
were going crazy in there and they were
barking at him and he stopped and looked
in a used its it looks kind of like he
does look like a little porker if
porkchop anyway when you when you bring
someone in you have a very very high
level are you a very very high standard
it stays on what training or pep talk or
anything do you do with these people
give me the silent treatment as soon as
I walk through the door basically you
give them sound let's see if they're
gonna crack yeah okay so no I'm just
kidding we don't we're just I do but my
staff doesn't my team doesn't Minoo in
terms of in terms of training you know
there is
I went through a long period of just
like the old school you know mentality
of like zero patience you know kind of
here here's here's what you know I don't
know just just that old school like
abusive mentality of cooking drill
sergeant yes drill sergeant you know
that kind of military ridiculousness
really right but that's evolved into
over the years of just you know going
back to kind of the martial arts thing
and you know just kind of remembering
you know that patience from from my
teachers and just from what martial arts
does in general so now it's really like
I like to you know if I if I can create
the you know the Google of restaurants
and that's that's really a nice thing
right and so it's a great goal for me in
terms of having a really exceptional
workplace and you know granted I don't
really know anything about Google at all
so I could it could be terrible I don't
know if I made from the outside who was
it that uh I was just listening to
somebody talk about you know from the
outside everybody's trying to get in and
from the inside I was trying to get out
or something yeah but I can see that I
mean the guy I know I have a lot of
friends at Google though and it seems to
be pretty acceptable yeah so that's
really the goal the goal now is really
is really mentorship and and how we can
create this kind of like package on the
inside to help our team navigate through
some really you know difficult and
enigmatic you know environment to
because there's always a gray area when
you start at a new place right you don't
really know everything that you need to
and even if you are a great cook let's
say and you start in a new kitchen at a
very high level then then there's gonna
be things you don't know every chef has
a different way to do things every
restaurant has a different SOP for
something and and so I wanted to slam
into practice yeah and standard
operating procedure yeah yeah and so I
wanted to create really this app
essentially that'll allow people to
operate every moment of their day like
Subway mmm this Subway's actually sucks
but right but uh I got a funny story
about Subway later on outside but uh but
and so that it gives people you know
this this huge influx of information so
they can be successful so that's kind of
the way we operate now we want people to
be mentored through the process and you
know in return they develop a loyalty to
that kind of you know patience that you
give them right and and then they wind
up you know really learning something
that's tangible because I want these
guys to come and work for us and you
know spend a few years there and it
really takes you know five years or so
to really learn about you know the
cooking at a at a certain you know a
certain kind of cooking certain level
when he's level if it's something like a
dick when I say that but but I just want
to use you know the certain type of
cooking and I wanted to be able to walk
away with something really tangible
where they can you know contributory
contribute and since you brought it up
subway tell me the story I might go to
jail after a taster there was a nice to
work in subway and there was always like
a little manual and I was I was probably
fifteen when I was sixteen sixteen
probably won't work there and we would I
don't know if I should tell the story we
would we can get it out later if you
change your mind let's go we would you
know it made me think of somebody
because of their manual they're
operating manual so my first my second
memory from Subway would be us
learning how to block out the cameras by
standing in strategic position putting
bubble gum on the end of a coat hanger
and fishing hundred other bills out of
the safe and a floor drop so we did that
for about a week and then I think we all
got fired after that cuz every nobody
knew what happened to the huntys yeah
wow that's some real like Ocean's eleven
the action at Subway who knew so my
contribution to subway I you know I've
always wanted ask you know I've never
asked you do you thought what's your
opinion of Francis Bauman if any I don't
know if you even know who I'm talking
about I know who you're talking about I
don't I don't know enough about him to
really give you my opinion I saw the
chef's table episode that he did that I
thought was really cool yeah I loved
that series
and he's very philosophical yeah but but
you know I it's funny it's cool I love
it's beautiful to see like what he's
doing out there in nature obviously he's
a legend he's been around for a long
time I don't know enough about it though
to really say anything meaningful but
but but I think it's amazing you know
looking at like him out in Patagonia and
there's like just pulling trout out of
the lake and I mean that for a chef
that's the ultimate right that's
actually something I've been working on
for years and years is just to get
myself to the woods it's just I could
stay in the woods I can gather I can
honican fish I can cook I can eat and
just be happy and that's kind of really
my goal of happiness is just to be out
there in the woods and and just you know
look there's a route I'm gonna dig it up
and I'm gonna cook it and it's gonna
taste great and we're gonna have some
wine together and we're all gonna
celebrate and have a great time and
that's that's that's what I'm looking
for so so I don't know I don't really
know enough about him I think that's the
burn ship he likes to British it that's
why it everywhere I don't really I don't
like burnt food like that so I okay so
you don't like these so you're talking
like the charming yeah I mean they're I
like food that has a delicacy to it so
this so it's very like like food that is
you know you got to think in terms of
volume right if you put on like what's
that like heavy metal band like GWAR
what it Wars or not you know you turn it
is to pick something like that I just
turn the volume all the way up in the
house and you're just then there's
that's like Guy Fieri right yeah he's
that skis core on level town okay so
they take so then you take let's just
use a really restaurant that I really
love and in the mountains of Kyoto and
they serve all wild foods from around
there really delicate the Bross are
under seasoned by our Western standards
and you know it's all about natural
taste but there's an incredible Beauty
to that food then that's a volume one
right and so that's really what we're
looking for in our world of cooking
right so so I don't I don't like the
level tens I like the level twos you
know around there yeah I would love to
just be a fly on the wall maybe sometime
we'll get down to Patagonia and have a
couple bottles of Malbec with with
Francis but what struck me there were a
handful cookbooks that really inspired
me when I was working on the 4-hour chef
which was very confusing
to most people a book about accelerated
learning kind of disguised as a cookbook
but seven fires which was by Francis
Bauman because he had the fancy French
training right but he chose to go back
to a lot of basics and but like refine
them to such a degree that they were
highly highly advanced from a kind of a
technical level right and then I think
it was just Mission Street food or
mission shiny is just a beautifully well
put together book a handful of others
there was another one on hunting and
foraging from the UK the name which I'm
blanking on at the moment
River maybe River has been sold the
ascator cool the TV show is what I was
my kind of like fantasy escape for all
the first I was it escaped from River
cottage or escape to River cottage by
Hugh phones Leigh weddings halt like the
but I think that's his name most British
name ever incredible books but that TV
show for people who fantasize about
getting out of the city and going back
to the land and hunting and foraging and
fishing I highly recommend the first
season of that series I check that out I
don't know if it's so good it's so good
is there I you gift books to people like
historically if you have you given books
as gifts if so yeah any that come to
mind they're all different I mean I'd
you know the one that I just gave out in
most recent history was there's an old
bar book it's called cocktail techniques
and it's from old have you seen now it's
a little tiny book and it's from the I
think it's the the guy from bar
high-five
he's like you know in Tokyo yeah sure it
just it's just about pure craft and
technique it's just called cocktail time
it's yeah it's cocktail techniques I
think and I think that's the guy could
be a different guy but but really cool
books I just gave it as out to a bunch
of my staff but the other one is the art
of Tai Chi Chuan
and it's it's or the DAO of Thai
judgment and it's by a guy named Joe
Seung why I think his name is uh
something along those lines but it's
really it's it's a really amazing book
on Tai Chi and it has a lot of
epiphanies in there because he started
Taichi when he was forty something
because of his bad house it was like on
his deathbed or something along those
lines you get cancer or something like
that and he he apparently you know went
through it started from being completely
unhealthy and then took his his journey
through tigey to to become one of the
foremost experts in america ontogeny my
world and starting at 40 yeah and and of
course within a few years just like
everybody else it does ties you they
become fixed essentially more or less
right as long as you're consistent your
practice you do it the right way
and you practice it for health than you
every I've seen a lot of people over the
years like you know car accidents or
whatever so that's one of my other
favorite books because there's a lot on
the application process and the actual
martial part of Taiji which is really
almost non-existent in China too it's
still almost non-existent not because
everything's kind of sport based ever
since ever since I suppose martial arts
became in essential once you know the
the you know firearms were created then
that was the downhill of you know
hand-to-hand combat write those down or
transit yeah it was like in necessity is
the mother of invention right it's like
once you don't have that as necessity
yeah everybody say oh thank God I could
just shoot this guy understand the horse
stance for 18 hours a day when you think
of the word successful who's the first
person who comes to mind I don't have a
person to me success is is living what
brings you joy you know and I think
doing whatever whatever process brings
you happiness I think is what success to
me and that's really that's really all
it is right because at the end of the
day it's freedom that matters and and
whatever that freedom is to each
individual is kind of what's important
so for me it's just being in the woods
at some point I'm just you dude and I'm
gonna disappear I'm gonna be in the
woods of so I'll see some the the like
that Montana free mental service I'm
holed out skiing
now I'm embarrassed to say hold on a
second so I've only heard you say your
last name once and it made me think that
I've been saying your last name
incorrectly for as long as I've had your
your name written anywhere in front of
me
so well okay so my family you know we
grew up saying it's Cannes skins but in
Scotland they say scheme Sheen is the
proper way to say it is the silent s
yeah I guess so yeah yeah maybe they say
Skeens - are you saying schemes
yeah just canes yes against the what is
the most joy that you felt in last three
months six months recent memory well for
those last six or you know three six
months I've actually been working on a
big deal for the company and so it would
have to bend last week when I closed the
deal because I could finally be the guy
I read so many legal documents in the
last in the last six months that I feel
like it could be a lawyer it's
mind-numbing it just it's it's so it's
so miserable in every way possible but
it's nice to get it done can you talk
about that or not yet no I can't talk
about it say there's a lot of exciting
stuff to happen here very very exciting
things and and you know this whole woods
thing is something that I've been
thinking about for years and years and
years because you know the fact of the
matter is is that to really get to the
highest level of your craft of cooking
you need to be submerged in the what's
going to be surrounded and isolated by
the wild really to really reach a
certain point it's the water it's the
air it's it's the the way the air tastes
when you're there it's everything
contributes to that it's the products of
course so but that's the open altra
geeky level of it you know it's like
there's it's only for a handful of
people that really enjoy that kind of
thing but most people enjoy being the
woods
if you could pick anywhere outside of
the US to immerse yourself in the
outdoors that way where would you pick
outside of the US I I guess you know my
whole life is just a few things it's
it's well I mean besides family the only
thing that I really you know
give a [ __ ] about her martial arts and
cooking mm-hmm and it's not just cooking
it's just it's the whole process the
whole act the whole commune with nature
you know being out in the wilderness and
being able to hunt your own meat and
it's not about the killing it's about
the the the sustenance that we get and
kind of the feeling that we get from
being part of that process also there's
like the consciousness and the reverence
in a way of having to go through the
entire process
yeah it's you have to treat things
differently once you experienced killing
another you know thing right another
living thing especially when you kill a
big animal like an elk and a deer
there's a very different feeling from
shooting a bird or something right even
though you know the bird III didn't you
know start doing that stuff until later
so to me they're all the same but but
yeah you you walk away with you know as
a cook especially you know knowing that
you're not gonna waste a single piece of
anything on that animal and I think
that's very important because a lot of
our this ties back into a way bigger
conversation which is about just our
commodity food processes in America and
and we are full of disease and [ __ ]
because of the way that we eat and the
way we treat our food you know is
feedlot cattle and and you know
chemically-induced you know vegetables
and crops and and you know most of our
food sources now are products that we
use on the commercial market or have
zero or you know almost very little
resemblance to what they originally were
and and and so you know that that's even
more reason to just what's that here so
where would you if you had if you had to
pick a spot outside the US - oh sorry no
no that's okay
I get off on these tangents you know the
I it takes one to know one
so that's you know I don't know I I I
was just looking at British Columbia my
picture my perfect place would be
mountain streams where where the
mountain streams meet the ocean really
you know and and that's that's kind of
the perfect place where it's so British
Columbia has a lot of that
I want to experience the Four Seasons
you know I want to see snow I want to
see the flowers in the spring and you
know want to have you know a bear walk
through the woods and potentially eat my
goat you know because it's a I there's a
cycle there there's a there's a cycle of
life and a cycle of you know things that
don't exist in a city anymore and we're
so removed from from just everything
really in a city in a lot of ways so so
I don't know location wise I'm I love
you sees a good choice yeah yeah I think
yeah amazing I was just looking at
buying there's a there's a hunting
territory up there that I wanted to buy
and it was really cheap and so we can
maybe we can go in on this
there was a [ __ ] you're not there was
there was a 250 square mile hunting
territory and you know the center of
that was I think 200 acres or something
like that right there's cabins on it
it's on a lake and the stream and it was
$500,000 Wow
so I you know I mean so she talked
naturally like before this gets go
before this podcast goes up
I dated a very lovely woman whose family
was from BC so I ended up spending quite
a lot of time up around Victoria and
some of the more the rural outskirts of
Victoria stunning I mean it's and we we
we wanted even you had to be cognizant
of bears and so on and so forth and I
spent so much time I'm trying to track
down
of course firearms very difficult to get
a hold of but this was while I was doing
all so that sort of refinement on the
4-hour chef and I wanted to go rabbit
hunting and I spent so much time trying
to track down high powered pellet guns
just call me I like slingshots a few but
it's a beautiful part of the world I did
a road trip
for those people interested with my
brother because I've done so many trips
between San Francisco and LA right San
Francisco South I think it's very common
they've never gone north so I did a road
trip with my brother from San Francisco
all the way up the coast to Whistler in
Canada
and stopped along the way at all these
escena lumberjack houses and so on and
Oregon saw the dunes that inspired the
book dune I think also in Oregon the
Avenue of the Titans and so on it's
amazing up north oh that's gorgeous
people search for those people
interested search my last name there's
nothing gems of the northwest or
something I highlight sixteen different
stops that we made but yeah there's I
spent a lot of time last fall going up
into like Hat Creek and and the like all
those Falls up there and so many ways up
there yeah it's incredible
Wow Shasta up around Shasta chest is
apparently like one of the vortexes in
the world whatever that means
I don't know what that means that's what
I heard
worth exploring I do you have what is
your what is your morning look like what
are your morning rituals and let's say
not necessarily when you're in like
hyper legal due diligence mode but let's
just say when when you're not covered in
that when I'm at peace again yeah what
did you want a Hong Kong milk tea and
Tai Chi to be honest that's what time do
you wake up it's always different and
very inconsistent with that I'm like one
day it'll be 1:00 p.m. the next day
it'll be 5:00 a.m.
got it it just depends what I do I love
the morning and I and I I if if I had my
perfect scenario it would just be you
know a cup of tea and and and some Tai
Chi and then get on with it
got it do you do you what type of tea
I'll come okay Hong Kong Hong Kong milk
tea yeah what is it
LT is like there there's a mixture of
black teas every place has their own
brew you know different types of leaves
can be Darjeeling or Ceylon Zoar or
whatever and then you essentially soak
it in water and you you over brew it in
some ways it's a very high ratio of
leaves to water and then you mix it with
evaporated milk and some people put
sugar or sweetened condensed milk in
there I just take it straight but but
it's something that I grew to love in
Hong Kong it was just an amazing thing
and all God I it's addictive it's a
highly highly addictive so that's what I
drink in the morning and then the Tai
Chi how long would
you practice that for what type of
Taichi you know I've gone as short is
like 37 seconds since some warnings to
like you know three hours just defense
it depends on the time I usually do like
a couple sets maybe like one set maybe
slow couple sets that's it yeah just
just to get the blood flowing injure to
rebalance yourself because here's a lot
of like one of the things about doing
doing these forms for the with the
intention of fighting and not with the
intention of performance or health is
that you you develop a certain kind of
like stability in your body and legs and
I've noticed that start to go away over
the last few years with just being busy
and stuff like that and you feel in your
knees I go in like when was going
hunting and stuff I was like wow this
this would have been super easy you know
for me a few years ago but now I feel
like [ __ ] Chris Farley I it's like
the worst it's really hard yeah I
noticed this very recently also doing I
mentioned when we were just making tea
before we started recording getting into
gymnastics training which I'm doing with
incredible coach named coach Chris
summer who's the former national team
coach and we're doing for the first time
I'm doing remote coaching so I'm sending
him videos he's reviewing we jump on the
phone etc that's it and one of the
series that I've been doing and I need
to start doing more consistently is this
knee sort of prehab rehabilitation
series all bodyweight that focuses on
strengthening say the ACL the cruciate
ligament etc these different types of
weird-looking squats and I did them for
say three weeks just once or twice a
week took maybe five minutes each
session and it was incredible how more
how much more stability I felt in my
knee is doing any type of movement any
type of walking hiking jumping and it
highlighted for me that that must mean
my knees were [ __ ] unstable as hell
beforehand if leg within two or three
weeks I felt a huge instability which I
guess is a symptom of just sitting down
too much also the way we moved to
you know jet I mean our our Western you
know patterns of movement a lot of ways
we're not a why is everyone's pattern of
movements was not very they're kind of
just like up-down left-right you know
computer you know bar yeah there's there
there's not a lot even much there's not
much lateral there's not a lot of
torsion of different types and you know
rotational exercise is pretty much out
the window for most folks so then when
you encounter that in any capacity its
forced upon you then you get injured
yeah you I'm sorry good no I just gonna
say there's some there's a there's a
some of the like the way in bagua they
isolate some movement patterns mind if I
have something for you know so in the in
and it's really just kind of an exercise
in in in balance and being able to learn
you know power versus resistance and you
have what do you mean mother well okay
so let's say you're let's say that you
are practicing a you know stance let's
say just for lack of a better example
without go into too much detail and and
that stance do you feel very stable in
that stance while you transition to
another stance and you're you know
undulating or rotating or going up and
down changing levels but that's without
pressure without resistance so let's say
you take that same technique or stance
or whatever and the pressure test didn't
apply another human being to push on you
or throw try to throw you while you do
that same thing so you basically are
pressure testing you know the reality of
some of these movements and in you know
you have to I mean before you do that
you have to have a lot of you know time
and solo practice with those movements
or stances and you know repetition okay
actually don't rip your knee out of
socket or something so don't go doing
this at home so you practice a little
bit but but the thing is is that it
brings us into reality to it because
that's always the problem with Chinese
martial arts that you see is there's no
reality to a lot of women it's never
very silly it's like it were tested
under the
no circumstances in which you would need
to use it yeah or or against bigger
people that or against real violence or
against any of those things that you
would you would need to actually make
something truly effective and so you
know that it but the point was is that
it develops your you know all of your
connective tissue and all of your body
and I've pretty sure the only reason
that I can't I can still walk is because
of my early years of martial arts in all
of this kind of stance work in
transition work and and you know that
kind of like twisting and turning of the
body and like Taichi and internal
martial arts very healthful for the body
I think that I think there's something
there and my interest in Tai Chi at one
point was pretty close to zero just
because so focused on the harder fight
sports like Muay Thai and so on
Brazilian jiu-jitsu and in the last say
five years my interest has really been
piqued by a friend of mine named Josh
Waitzkin who's been on this but I'll
just have like a podcast small world
story real quick so I get this text one
point from Matt Mullenweg who's the I
guess he's CEO of automatic right now
and was one of the lead developers of
WordPress and he goes I was walking with
my girlfriend through New York Central
Park or somewhere no wasn't central part
was near the water I said we saw this
guy doing some weird martial arts stuff
right on the water and so I was
commenting on it and how it looked
really beautiful to my girlfriend she
said well you should walk up and say hi
so it walked up and said hi and it was
another person who'd put on the podcast
Josh Waitzkin doing Taichi now Josh was
the basis for searching for bobby
fischer's movie about this chess prodigy
which he was when he was a kid but he's
also a he was a push hands world
champion and then after that became the
first black belt under Marcelo Garcia
who's like the Michael Jordan Mike Tyson
Wayne Gretzky combined a Brazilian
jiu-jitsu and I always associated Tai
Chi with non martial applications right
but he uses this and has prescribed it
to his parents who've seen fantastic
results for rehab prehab just lie
stability and well-being in general so
even though he has a tremendous amount
of experience with BJJ at an extremely
high level he still does the Tai Chi on
a regular basis we just made me think
that there's that I should probably make
space for a practice of that type I'll
tell you what there's a there's a lot
more to it than you then you know most
people give credit for because the
reason is that there's no good Tai Chi
really anywhere right so it's very and
Josh would agree with you but yeah and
just imagine you know if you had no good
you know
jiu-jitsu anywhere yeah and you know
then everybody make fun of it because
these guys are just get on the ground
get stomped yeah right but you know if
it's the same thing it's the same the
same would apply to any kind of system
and and so but once you if you if you
really you know happen to be lucky
enough to stumble upon someone who's
truly really great at the martial side
of Tai Chi then you know it's all it's
kind of like this immovable Mountain
thing and and you know my take on it is
that in terms of like real mart real
applicable martial arts which means
being able to defend yourself against
someone who's using real violence mmm
I'm not talking about sport which is
still very difficult right I mean that's
not but but to really be able to defend
yourself against real violence is a
different kind of ball of wax right and
oftentimes that requires less a less of
a lot of things in a sport would right
you don't need to train for 20 hours a
day to be able to get to that point you
don't have to have amazing cardio
necessarily you know know a lot of
things go out the window
due to this kind of ability to evade
right and evasion is not in a large
circle it's really can be a very small
thing like let's say you a simple
example would be lets say that you
practice standing with your knees bent a
little bit to the point to where you
would you know fall over the first day
and for 20 years you practice that same
kind of standing against somebody trying
to push you over right well eventually
you get to the point to where he can't
be pushed over right and you went
through a series of different opponents
and different
people trying to you know throw you over
but that's all you practice forever
right and so Taiji develops that kind of
skill right when it's done in the
martial sense but then you're able to
mobilize it so you let's say you take
the static you know a starting point of
being immobile movable doesn't mean
you're actually movable it means you're
adjusting your body to the other person
right and to there their force that's
coming towards you you're adjusting a
little bit right and it's not this whole
there's a lot of like you know
hokey-pokey [ __ ] out there on people
that don't really that's a philosophy
but there's no real applicable you know
reality to it so that's one thing and
the other thing is just kind of the the
ability to evade like if you're if you
have let's say you take you know a Thai
boxer who what I guy who can kick relief
[ __ ] hard that guy practice kicks
every day is professional type of action
what we have to realize is that the
distance there's just a distancing thing
right at the point of impact of
anybody's kick or punch or attack is one
place once they release that you know
intention what's the intention leaves
the you know the mine and goes into the
body and the action is created and it's
traveling towards your opponent there's
a target there's an intended target if
you can change yourself from being that
intended target you know the origin of
that and reroute yourself only a few
inches then all of that force goes away
right and so it's a it's a it's a simple
kind of thing to say but you know just
to be able to do that with one punch or
one kick it takes a lifetime to learn
right and I'm not saying I know these
things I'm just saying that that's
there's a couple simple truths that I've
learned from it that that are that's a
couple but I'm so yeah so I think that
that Taichi is very applicable because
you know I go out and practice with over
the years or practice some really
amazing MMA guys some really amazing
jujitsu guys and you see a translation
from this kind of traditional martial
arts but only very little it's not like
overall you know you can't just go get
in the cage you know it's not so but
there are there are some really great
things that I think that you know it'd
be really interesting to see
I would love to see you know
professional fighters start to explore
that a little bit but the issue is that
that to even get remotely efficient at
those kinds of things it takes at least
ten years of like daily practice yeah
right and so that might be the challenge
but in your careers over time budgeting
issue the how old you know thirty six
thirty six what advice would you give
your thirty year old self if you could
place us where you were and what you
were doing at that time I know I think I
think it would be to take a step back
right take a step back really slow down
and really really think through what
really you know matters in the long run
right because we're you know what were
you doing at the time when you're so
thirty well but well my but I guess the
actually my thirty year old self that's
different cuz that's when I just started
cezanne you know so I was doing the same
thing I'm doing now only in a more kind
of ridiculous way but I'm my 20 year old
self 25 yeah you know 25 year old self
yeah I mean I think it would be to just
really take a step back and and not get
caught up in anything stupid because you
know a lot of times when we're chasing
success or what we think is success like
trying to as a chef you want to build a
big name you want to you know get three
Michelin stars you want to get the
accolades but ultimately know that [ __ ]
matters it matters in the beginning and
it certainly matters along the way but
but if you if we all just take a step
back and I think there's a bigger lesson
to be learned for the way that we
operate as a society's is to really
focus on what really matters to us and
is what is genuinely makes us happy then
we'll travel down the right path right
and we won't get sidetracked by you know
you know tits and ass or whatever you
you know Fame and sports cars and all
silly [ __ ] that you don't need and
unless those are the things that really
make you happy well do you make us happy
but there
but I but I mean that you know if what
really makes you happy is getting in the
woods then you know you focus you're
able to really take step back and focus
on quality maybe if you want to be a
cook you want to be a chef
what kind of chef do you want you want
to be you want to be a Instagram chef or
you want to be a you know chef with a
real quality and skill that's
respectable
you know respected by the world you know
for your your ethos or something so
they're just you know I would say get
your head out of your ass
probably my summary what were you what
were you getting just what were you
distracted by or focusing on at 25 that
you shouldn't have been my
parents-in-law don't hear this it's just
like two people in this podcast if I
yeah I mean I was just I was just
cooking oh actually you know I was a
chef at a restaurant called Shay TJ I
don't place in Mountain View yeah sure
I'd spin there for like 30 years and I
shortly after that got poached by
Michael Mina to do some development work
open arrests for a restaurant for him
down in the st. Regis in Orange County
as a temporary gig and then went to work
with him when kind of the just to learn
business from him right I wanted to
learn some business I don't know
anything about business at all and I
wanted to see kind of how that operated
and function as a restaurant group so a
lot of it was like Vegas and partying
and partying all the time and just just
ridiculousness I mean we would go out
after work Oana then go home at sunrise
and wake up and 4:00 p.m. and go back to
like the kitchen the next day just come
and just immediately need like a whiskey
because you're so hungover it was the
only care of the dog so so that was a
good few years of my life just kind of
going crazy and because I you know I
wasn't all I did was train so I didn't
do that when I was younger like I had a
period of my teenage years where I was a
lunatic and then I I went back into
training around 15 and fun pulled out of
that
then and then I didn't really even drink
until I was 25 after I got my chef's job
and so you know a couple of couple
makeups were lost time yeah the I I feel
like oftentimes reflecting back in my
high school career and college
experience that if I had not had
competitive sports I'm in Hooton I would
would have ended up in skid row or in a
gutter god knows well for sure if I if
I'd have martial arts that'd be dead in
the gutter that's for sure yeah where
would you like to have food that you
have not yet had food the exciting food
to me is you know the original peoples
of wherever whatever location so if we
go to in Australia and have some
Aboriginal traditional food and kind of
explore that side of things and in in
nature and and the same thing with
anywhere else so if you go to any
country or any place and kind of you
know exploring the the natural foods
that existed before commodification you
took place that's what that's what's
very interesting to me I was playing
with I had a lot of fun messing around
with it there's guy named cliff Hodges
who's also in the 4-hour chef he makes
his own bows and arrows like from
scratch and hunted black bear with his
nose with his I guess they're Osage bows
I want to say they're incredible but he
introduced me to cooking on fire so he
he is a outdoor survival expert and she
taught me how to build debris huts and
whatnot knows how to track really
interesting guy you'd get a kick out and
lives in Santa Cruz Mountains and he
where was I going with this
oh he introduced me to a cornmeal and
making things out of acorns which I
looked into it at one point it
represented for certain indigenous North
American tribes a substantial portion of
their total calories a quart
yeah and I got really that summer I'm
really interested in leeching acorns and
making things out of acorns
yes delicious yeah really really good I
mean that's the thing about our
foodstuffs now is that were there's so
many amazing things and that's kind of
what saison does at the moment is that
we're you know it's just exploring
what's here the native foods I mean what
is what exists really had a really you
know incredible quality and there's all
kinds of [ __ ] here there's something
like we get you know we set up a program
with fishermen where we get only live
fish in our tanks right they bring us
fish that's alive or we don't want it
and that way we can kill it a certain
way they kid you may and control the
process and and the same thing with like
all the commercial fisheries or or the
the vegetables the produce we have wild
Kiwis in the woods and Marin there's
well that Kiwis yeah I mean there's
acorns there's ginseng root growing
there's berries there's all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] around there's a diamond
turbo in the waters here there's pink
scallops there's monkey face eels so
we're exploring those they're just gonna
funky looking things and they're really
delicious too yeah yeah you know like
you just cook it let's say you cook it
like unagi or something right yeah just
yeah there's all these amazing things
around in in our in each location around
the country and and the Pacific happens
to be amazing because of the ocean but
the the you know the cold climate of the
ocean but that's a very exciting kind of
food right to just really kind of look
at what's around us like really explore
what's around us it's nothing new it's
been done it was being done before all
this other [ __ ] was being done and so
but that's really where great food comes
from great food comes from not from
growing it on a farm but from really
exploring the wild and finding you know
that kind of reference point for flavor
right like you find the you find the
best fish during the best season or the
best the you know bear during after
eating the blueberries
during the rites you know so there's all
these in the same thing with produce and
a lot of stuff so those are that's a
very exciting way to cook
well he pretty soon I'm gonna have a
restaurant that only does that it's
gonna take six hours to get to and maybe
I'll just do it for one table night and
you know maybe you're part of the
hunting process who knows or you know go
out and catch our trout no man if you
need if you needed guinea pig to take it
for a test drive come in the NICU you
did this makes me think a little bit of
an experiment that you did I'm not sure
how recently this was but the chef's
table rotation that you did with help me
out with the name here zero zero yeah
but not the general area yeah that's
right yeah but zero who was cooking I
guess previously in Noe Valley sir yeah
yeah he but he was trained in Tokyo he
was a sushi chef in Tokyo and I just I
love a sushi he has so he has that
timing you know has a sensibility to the
the flavor of his sushi and and and
unfortunately in San Francisco there's
no good sushi at all and I really wish
there were but there isn't and so that's
why I fell in love with his sushi
because it was so delicious had the warm
the right the rice was a little warmer
had the right texture you know the
thickness of the cuts of the fish the
way the direction in which you cut
against the grain or with the grain you
know the balance of the seasoning just
everything was there and so for a period
of time I don't know how long it was but
he would seat how many people per night
people yeah so I built this little for
those who don't know I built this little
chef's counter out next essays on and it
was it was her behind saison and it was
eight seats and there were no turns
there's no real commodity to the
situation I guess you know returns
meaning well somebody wouldn't get up
and get replaced by another diner right
exactly and in today's real estate for
the cost of renting a place paying for
labor you know all these other things
insurances and taxes on ship you have to
do more than one seating right you have
to you know get as many people in there
as you can which is a very sad state of
restaurants
when you're trying to you know do things
are really amazing or give people great
experience but so this was just a little
aid seat workshop essentially and so he
cooked in there for a while we would do
some collaboration dinners and it was
really great but then I realized we're
still in the city and you know you can't
there's only so much you can do on a
busy street with a dump truck driving by
you know so yeah so so I've been working
on some new stuff and one day I'll be
able to tell you about it and why the
80s music you always have great 80s
music playing at least in my experience
so far
what's it just fun it's a it's a
restaurant that's in the it's pleasure
it's about pleasure it's about enjoyment
it's about people coming and I know not
everybody's going like 80 music but the
substantial majority of our our subset
of diners that come in like you know
that kind of 80 music and it's just fun
yeah that's the only reason it's just
about fun speaking of fun Molly just got
on Bubba
so Chester is gonna have play made here
there she is
almost went for a yard sale with so it's
really it's really just about the whole
the whole reasoning of Cezanne was about
those ascent the essential nature of
hospitality experience the food being
what we talked about earlier the the
eighties music being fun you know the
things you pick up in your hands feeling
good the the seat being comfortable the
service being warm and real you know you
know so that that's kind of why they a
music camp about well what I love about
the we have a couple glasses wine eating
I was gonna say that I've had I've taken
a few friends to saison and they've
always they've always had questions
about the eighties music and then they
get a few dishes in maybe a glass or two
of wine and they're like you know this
music
suiting to this experience and I always
have to ask people when they wouldn't
because I've been in San Francisco for
so long and I get questions about places
to go to eat and I always have to ask
you know
it's your budget and what's the occasion
because say Zhaan's that's a higher end
despise higher end I mean I'm grasping
for a better adjective it's expensive
it's an expensive comparatively to other
projects yeah it's creatively expensive
place but for an anniversary or
something like that or just a special
experience I think it's it's always been
my go-to on the opposite end of the
spectrum if I'm like if you want a
really filthy delicious burrito in the
mission and I think El Farolito if you
want to like also have a conversation
with a couple of meth heads then that is
the sponsors my preferred the choice of
meal no conversation yeah yeah and our
dogs are playing folks but so Joshua we
can keep talking forever where can
people find you online on the socials
learn more about what you're up to I
think your Instagram is fantastic also
if you want to see a lot of very very
peculiar and delicious ingredients and
that's a good place to see you but we're
working people find you yeah J Instagram
is chase Gaines
JSK en es almost forgot my aunts mother
kids on Instagram or on Twitter I think
it's saison SF saison SF and the website
also is SF calm and I will put all this
in the show notes folks including links
to anything that we might have mentioned
our dogs are having a blast
speaking of joy so you can find the show
notes at 4 hour work week comm forward
slash podcast Josh thanks for taking the
time man
thanks for having me here man see ya
look lining now well absolutely let's go
hang and have some wine in that order
and everybody listening we're gonna play
with the dogs and until next time thank
you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email from me
every Friday the vet provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favourite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoyed
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is a great partner
for creating and growing your business
it's a one-stop shop for all of your
graphic design needs whether that's a
logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one year
Times bestseller
I also use them for banner ads
illustrations and other things with
99designs designers around the world to
compete to create the best design for
you you give feedback and then pick your
favorite you end up happy or you get
your money back it's very simple you can
check out a few of my own designs and
those of yours meaning Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs comm forward
slash of Tim and right now my listeners
you guys will get a free $99 upgrade on
your first design that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim check it out
this episode is brought to you by
headspace more than 80% of the people I
have interviewed world-class performers
across the military entertainment sports
and beyond all have some type of
meditative practice I tried for years
and years and failed miserably the key
is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than 4 million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder and II put it combs TED talk
which has more than 5.5 million views
his last name is PUD bi c om b e if you
want to look that up but otherwise
download the free headspace app I have
it on my phone and begin there take ten
program for ten days of guided
meditation completely free ten minutes a
day that's all it takes you should give
it a shot
headspace calm forward-slash Tim just go
to headspace calm forward-slash Tim and
until next time thank you for listening